Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
You probably just saw the news
in your feeds this morning.
As of last week,
Marvel has completely blown up.
Daredevil born again.
They're basically wiping the show
from the planet in its current form
will completely change it from the ground
up in a number of different ways
in a lot of the reason why is to address
the larger problems with Marvel's
quality control the last few years Aren't
you supposed to talk about my show
with your show?
I think you mean my show.
So I'll explain what's going on
as bad as that sounds like them
canceling
what we know is Daredevil born again,
completely coming back with something
totally different.
This is actually a good thing.
We're still getting new Daredevil
episodes.
Eventually it'll just be something
completely different
than what
they were originally going to do.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Of course,
I'll do episodes for Daredevil Born Again
when it eventually does premiere.
We're in the middle of Loki season
two episodes.
The Loki series is actually
pretty relevant to this conversation
and what's happening
behind the scenes at Marvel right now.
It's like this huge creative reimagining
of the way that they make
television shows just in general.
but the Loki series is
one of the few examples of them doing
something really good.
Despite all these creative misses.
but if you haven't seen the news
Marvel or Kevin Feige
essentially fired
the entire creative team behind
Daredevil born again
a few weeks ago is part of a larger change
that he was making to the entire way
that they make TV shows just in general.
apparently they were having
a lot of problems
with the Daredevil Born Again
episode specifically.
But they were making larger changes
to the way that they make television
shows just in general.
So there were a bunch of things
that they're changing.
Daredevil Born Again is just part of that.
before the writers strike started earlier
this year, Marvel had filmed
less than half of the planned 18 Daredevil
born again Season one episodes.
They're going to be 18 episodes total.
That might change a little bit,
like they might go to 20 episodes.
We'll see.
but the writers strike
forced everyone to stop filming on
pretty much everything like Hollywood,
basically shut down for a while,
not just Marvel and during the strike,
according to Variety.
Hollywood Reporter A lot of people
that are reporting on this Kevin Feige
review what they'd shot
so far from Daredevil born Again
in, decided that it just was not working
like it was not up to par
and people were going to be pissed again
there's so much riding on daredevil
burning it.
Like people are hoping that
that's going to be a big creative return
to quality marvel
the same way that they're hoping
that Loki season two
is going to do that as well.
apparently Kevin Feige felt like the stuff
that they'd done for Daredevil Born Again
so far was not going to live up to that,
according to the report,
which gets into a little bit more detail,
the writers, directors, producers
had basically turned Daredevil born again
into more of a legal procedural
like those episodes of She-Hulk
with Daredevil minus
some of the over-the-top
comedy in fourth Wall breaking.
But it was more of a legal show
and less of an action packed drama
like the original Daredevil
Netflix episodes, which is what most
people, myself included,
were expecting from Daredevil, Born Again.
Generally, just way more action
packed show now that they have all
Marvel's money, that they have that Disney
money, infinite money for the most part,
you would expect them to do a much more
comic book version of Daredevil things
that they just couldn't
pull off with the Netflix budget,
which was much smaller than the budget
that Marvel now has available to them
for example, the report details
that Daredevil would not have even put
on his daredevil suit until episode four.
And when episode one picks up,
it's meant to take place
after the events of the Echo series
because Daredevil and Kingpin
are much bigger characters during that.
those episodes are supposed to release
in January.
I'll do episode videos for that
when it does release.
But when Daredevil Born Again episode
one picks up after a small time jump
after the end of Echo,
Matt Murdock has essentially hung up
the suit like Spider-Man two,
when Tobey Maguire Spider-Man throws away
the suit temporarily.
Matt Murdock has a version of this
and this is just a rumor.
But apparently the reason for him
quitting being Daredevil
was the death of either
Foggy Nelson or Karen Page.
Maybe both of them like they were supposed
to be killed in the first episode.
My guess is that it was at least foggy.
Nelson
you remember hearing all the reports
about Foggy Nelson, Karen Page
not being big characters
during season one.
Apparently, that was the reason.
could you even imagine
if this is the way that things had gone
down, that they'd released episodes
like this, people would have rioted.
But this wasn't the only reason
why Kevin Feige
basically pulled the plug on this
original version of Daredevil Born Again.
the the other major reason is
they're completely changing
the way they make television shows.
So this gets really inside baseball like
this is how the sausage is made at Marvel.
pull back the curtain to see
what the Wizard of Oz is actually doing.
what Marvel did when they started doing
the big budget Disney Plus TV shows
is try to hack the way that television
is made to make things quicker.
The same way that they hacked movie
making to get their movies out faster.
mostly because they'd had so much success
with Avengers Endgame
in the last ten years
of Marvel. Up to that point,
like they've been so successful
at hacking the movie,
making out of the like,
we can figure out Tony
pretty much all the people in Marvel
that were making the shows,
or at least in charge
of calling all the shots on the TV shows
had no experience
in making TV shows at all.
Like they had no idea.
even the top brass, like Nate Moore,
for example, who's the lead producer
on a lot of their biggest movies
like Black Panther.
What kind of rubber admitted,
We have no idea how to make television
shows, which is figure out along the way.
So Marvel starts making their TV shows,
assembly line style,
the way that they make all their movies,
thinking that it's
totally going to work out for them
the way that making movies did
in as you would guess
this is how they fail hard because making
television
shows is a completely different endeavor
like requires a completely different skill
set than making movies.
There are things that you can do on movies
to fix movies.
After you finished shooting them,
like fixing it in post, finding the movie,
and that you can't
really do on a TV schedule.
So that's why you have a bunch of TV shows
that are coming out with some episodes
that are just not up to par.
Like, Well, how come they didn't fix this
because they didn't have time to film it
or reshoot it the way they would have
if it had been a movie.
basically
Marvel has this mindset of fix it in post
basically the way that Marvel makes movies
and this goes back all the way to Iron
Man one, like they've done
all their movies this way.
They'll hire writers to develop a script.
Then they'll change the script every day
as they're filming.
For example, in Spider-Man
No Way Home, Tom Holland said
that they rewrote the script
every single day.
So if you asked him what was happening
in Act Three when they started filming
the movie, he would have no idea.
Like even the director, John Wise,
who's a really solid director,
had absolutely no idea
what was going to be happening
at the end of the movie
when they started filming the movie.
so marvel way back since Iron
Man one basically has been driving
this really fast train, laying the track
in front of it as it's moving.
That's how they were able to get out three
plus movies per year.
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy is like the opposite example
that he took three years
to get the next Batman movie out, The Dark
Knight, Then he took another four years
to get The Dark Knight Rises down
because he just felt like he needed
that extra year, more time
to just make a much better movie,
to make a better story, just in general.
whereas Marvel,
the quality control problem
goes back to them trying to get stuff out
super quick.
And then Bob Iger, Bob Chapek
especially as the pandemic started to hit,
starting to force them to produce
even more and more content
in the special sauce at Marvel,
at least up to this point, has been Kevin
Feige just completely focusing on a movie
and retooling it,
making it again and again and again
while they're still filming the movie
to make it as good as it can possibly be.
but here's the thing.
There's only one Kevin Feige,
and he can only do so much work.
So you start producing way,
way more stuff in general,
like way more movies at the same time, way
more television shows at the same time.
Even this year, like 2023, originally
they had scheduled to release up
to like six series this year.
when this started happening, Kevin
Feige just lost the ability to focus on
each of the different projects.
So we had to delegate a lot of the task
to his other producers,
who also have no experience
in making TV shows.
and that's where the cracks in the quality
control problems start to happen.
that's why they delayed a lot of stuff.
They're back to doing
just three movies per year
and they're only doing a couple of series
per year.
and in the last couple of weeks
Kevin Feige has changed
Marvel's method for making TV shows
to make everything work more like
traditional TV shows are made Now.
Marvel is hiring dedicated television
executives who have experience
in actually making good television
shows to manage all the shows
Previously, they just forced all their
movie producers to work on the TV shows,
even though they had no experience
in doing that.
in, whereas before Marvel would greenlight
hundred and $50 million $200 million
TV shows without a pilot episode
or a showrunner like Secret Invasion,
for example, which was a disaster for them
behind the scenes cost over
$200 million to make Now Marvel's changing
that.
They'll have traditional
showrunners, traditional writers rooms
managing the story episode to episode,
going to set,
making sure things
don't fly off the rails,
making sure it all makes sense,
changing things the way that they needed
to be changed on the fly in No more,
I repeat, no more six episode events.
they're basically not trying to make
bloated movies and just chopping them up
into six different episodes.
they're going to start focusing on longer
episode runs like 10 to 12 episodes
per season
and multiple seasons of serialized TV
shows like you would normally expect,
giving characters time to develop
and people time to connect with them.
whereas before, they were more focused
on these limited series,
like the six episode events for example,
The Falcon and Winter Soldier
series was basically a failed movie.
They took the script from that,
dusted it off of their shelf
and broke it into six episodes.
That's why it fell all over the place.
one of the happy accidents
that they've had in all this mess
the last couple of years was Loki
season one.
That was like the diamond in the rough.
It was amazing.
But here's the thing
they never actually planned to do
Loki season two
when they were making season one.
That's why season two
is taking so long to get out
and why none of the writers from season
one came back for season two
Because they'd already moved on
to other projects when Marvel said, Hey,
why don't we do a season two now
going forward, they're basically planning
on doing multiple seasons
from the beginning
that all their creative staff,
the actors don't take off
after the first season and it takes them
like four years to get season two out.
so as much as it sucks to see Daredevil
born again get delayed to 2025 while
they hire totally new writers,
showrunners,
directors
to do a completely different story.
I would much rather
wait a little bit longer
if it means getting a really,
really good version of a Daredevil show.
Generally, Marvel is making
all these changes on all their TV
shows that they're filming starting now.
Daredevil
Born Again is just like the first example
that there are a lot of shows
that they've already finished filming
that they'll probably try to retool
with the extra time
behind the scenes to make better.
But for the most part,
all the brand new stuff starting today
is going to be part of this new Marvel
method of making TV shows, basically Kevin
Feige pulling a hard reset like unplug,
then plug it back in on Marvel television.
Now, a lot of you are asking me
if they're going to completely change
everything about Daredevil born again.
What's the new plot going to be like?
What's the new story?
The variety reports is they'll use
some of the footage they shot already, but
they hadn't filmed half the episodes yet,
but they filmed a lot of stuff.
so some of the plot elements will be
the same.
Like Kingpin will still be running
for mayor of New York City
like he did in the comics.
Punisher will still be coming back
in a big part of season one.
Jessica Jones.
The other Netflix defender
characters will eventually come back to
they'll probably bring back Foggy
Nelson and Karen Page in a bigger way
and not kill them off
in the first episode in
even though I think that they plan
to do season two before this,
they're definitely going to do
Daredevil Born Again Season two.
the new release date
will probably be closer to spring 2025.
That's my expectation right
now, Closer to the time
they're releasing Captain America
four Brave New World.
they might change some of the post-credits
scenes in the Daredevil
episodes and references to be more current
to what's happening in the MCU.
While that's happening
because it's happening a little bit later,
but generally a lot of the really big plot
elements like the whole mare kingpin of it
all will stay the same.
most of the changes
they just announced address
most of my complaints
that I've had the last couple of years
about Marvel TV just in general generally
the Loki series has been like the diamond
in the rough,
like the exception to a lot
of these quality control issues so far.
I think that Season two
has been really solid my fall.
Loki Season
two Episode two video will post on Friday
after they release it just like normal.
click here for that video.
Update the link as soon as I post
that and click here to learn about
the Big Scarlet Witch Easter Egg
in the last big Loki Post-Credits scene.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.